luego de declarar la amnistía migratoria
del proceso de regulación por el
presidente de ecuador guillermo lasso
hace tres meses mediante decreto oficial
el jugador deberá regular un promedio de
un millón de personas de los cuales 363
mil son venezolanos que ingresaron de
forma regular a este país
393.000 de otras nacionalidades y
300.000 más aproximadamente que
ingresaron de forma irregular según
datos del ente oficial el proceso se
dividirá en tres fases y comenzará el
primero de septiembre y culminará el 15
de agosto del año 2023 la primera fase
atenderá a los venezolanos que
ingresaron al país por un punto oficial
ciudadanos de otras nacionalidades que
ingresaron de manera regular a partir
del 16 de noviembre y desde el 17 de
febrero del año 2023 se atenderá a
quienes ingresaron de manera irregular
este proceso contempla una visa temporal
y un certificado de permanencia que
tendrá una vigencia de dos años
renovable
este registro verificará los
antecedentes penales del solicitante en
ecuador' que exigirán antecedentes
penales desde el país de origen
de este proceso es la inquietud que
genera en algunos extranjeros porque el
ecuador aseguró que el país busca
controlar los altos niveles de
criminalidad existentes en el país con
la otorgación de visas temporales al
igual que exhortó a la población
ecuatoriana no consideran una amenaza a
los extranjeros como los causantes de la
criminalidad en ecuador
organizaciones venezolanos en el cuadro
cuestionaron el colapso de la plataforma
encargada del registro oficial y
demandaron pronunciamiento por parte de
la fen soria del pueblo y cuestionaron
que viola algunos derechos humanos de
los solicitantes este es el segundo
registro migratorio que realiza el país
andino